Häh, warum sieht die Quali so kacke aus?
Watt!
Ach, meine Auflösung ist falsch, lul.
Geht gut.
Das ist ein guter Titel, das muss ich jetzt gleich ändern.
Das ist auch ein bester Titel.
So, also, ich warte mal bis noch ein paar Leute da sind, weil es bringt dann nichts,
wenn ich jetzt erzähle, was wir heute machen und es ist noch keiner da.
Was ist das, fragt DxVinstea, ja, meinst du Git oder meinst du das, was du im Hintergrund
siehst?
Hallo, Opa-Burger.
Git!
Git ist ein Versionsverwaltungssystem oder eine, oh, wie schreiben sie offiziell, eine
dezentrale Versionsverwaltung oder so.
Komm mal gucken, was die selbst sagen, was sie sind.
Ja gut, it's a version control system, da wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen.
Was sagen sie denn selbst, was sie sind?
Git easy to learn, lightning fast, das sind immer die besten Intros.
Ups.
Das ist noch die Textdatei, wo ich meinen neuen Rechner geplant habe, aber der neue
Rechner ist ja mittlerweile am Start.
Ja, wir gucken uns heute Git an, weil, hat einen ganz speziellen Grund, ich hab das ja
auch vor einer Weile schon mal angekündigt oder gefragt, besser gesagt, ob ich das machen
soll, ob wir uns mal so Git-Grundlagen angucken wollen, sollen, wie auch immer und nachdem
ich jetzt schon überraschend viele Leute immer mal wieder gefragt haben, wann es das
denn jetzt gibt, hab ich mir gedacht, ah ja, go, go, go, da war das jetzt mal.
Also ich kann jetzt sagen, also wer jetzt Call of Duty haben will, das mach ich vielleicht
später noch ein paar Runden, aber jetzt machen wir erstmal Git-Grundlagen.
Mal so in die Runde gefragt, so an die Leute, die schon da sind, habt ihr erstens eine Ahnung,
was man mit einem Versionsverwaltungssystem macht oder mit einem Software, Source Code
Versionssystem, Versionssystem, wie auch immer man es genau nennen mag, und habt ihr schon
mal was mit Git gemacht?
Git-Clone, Git-Clone ist, das haben wahrscheinlich die meisten, das ist das erste, was man damit
macht.
Also ich mein, GitHub werden wahrscheinlich auch die meisten kennen, weil man sagen muss,
dass GitHub mit Git eigentlich erstmal gar nichts zu tun hat, GitHub ist ein Web-Frontend
und hat mit Git an sich nichts zu tun.
Du hast Git benutzt, um deine Hausaufgaben an der Uni abzugeben, echt, muss man Hausaufgaben
mit Git hochladen, auch nicht schlecht.
Sivuri hat es auch schon benutzt, ja es gibt da mittlerweile für so ziemlich jedes Betriebssystem
entweder Pakete oder irgendwas fertig zum installieren oder irgendwelche IDE-Extensions, was auch
immer, ist der Sound eigentlich von der Lautstärke her so ok, mal kurz gucken, oder soll ich
den Sound auch ein bisschen leiser machen, also man kann das ja mittlerweile echt auf
jedem Betriebssystem benutzen, ja, aber bevor wir uns jetzt so die Git-Grundlagen angucken
können, müssen wir eine Sache noch machen, nachdem ich keinen Lust habe jetzt irgendeinen
GitHub-Account vollzumüllen mit irgendwas, installieren wir uns oder hab ich ein Git-Management-Web-Frontend
schon mal hier lokal bei mir installiert, was fast aussieht wie GitHub, wo wir da unser
Repo anlegen können, das wir auch mal zu einem Remote-Server pullen können oder von einem
Remote-Server pullen können und zu einem Remote-Server pushen können und sowas in
der Richtung, Lola ausauf kam ja verbraucht, er macht das schon, so, jetzt mal die Frage,
ich muss da selbstfalls ein bisschen reinkommen, ich hab mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so viele
Gedanken gemacht, wie wir am besten anfangen, zumindest, zumindest GitHub werden wahrscheinlich
die meisten Leute kennen, zum Beispiel der Linux-Könnel ist auf GitHub, der South-Code
vom Linux-Könnel ist auf GitHub, so, da ist er, den klonen wir uns jetzt aber nicht, weil
das ist saumäßig groß, ich weiß gar nicht wie lange das mittlerweile dauert, sich den
Linux-Könnel zu klonen, also da ist, es hat auch ein paar Comets und so mittlerweile, oder
was, was ist das für eine nervige Musik, so, es ist von Google beispielsweise auch ganz
viel Software auf GitHub, öffentlich verfügbar, auch im Linux-Könnel, aber von Google gibt's
auch viel, Microsoft hat Visual Studio Code, auch auf GitHub, den South-Code, ja, Mr.
Milchmann, den Linux-Könnel klonen ist so eine Sache für sich, da würde ich aufpassen,
das dauert ewig und ist ziemlich groß, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es mit Git alles relativ
schnell, wenn man es erstmal geklont hat, so, was wir jetzt als erstes machen, ist wir
installieren uns mal so einen kleinen eigenen GitHub-Klon, den wir als Web-Frontend verwenden
können, wohlgemerkt, das Web-Frontend hat mit Git unten drunter, also mit dem eigentlichen
Tool überhaupt nichts zu tun, das macht bloß die Verwaltung und die Zusammenarbeit, wenn
man mit mehreren Leuten oder auch alleine an unterschiedlichen Projekten in Repos arbeitet,
ein bisschen einfacher, und nachdem viele Leute mit GitHub arbeiten, dachte ich mir,
es ist genauso wichtig, so ein bisschen das zu zeigen, anstatt nur rein Git auf der Kommando-Zeile,
denn wir gucken uns Git an, so wie es gedacht ist, nämlich mit den Kommando-Zeilen-Tools,
es gibt für fast jede Entwicklungsumgebung mittlerweile Addons, wo man das quasi mit
irgendeinem GUI rumklicken kann, gibt's für Eclipse beispielsweise, hat den besten Namen
überhaupt, heißt EGIT, passt zu Eclipse, es hört gleich so richtig an, EGIT, aber es
ist halt auch Eclipse, da muss man sich nicht wundern, es gibt für aber alle anderen Ideas
mittlerweile, entweder schon eingebaut oder aber zum Unterladen, Git Extensions, Visual
Studio Code hat's eingebaut, Visual Studio selbst hat's mittlerweile glaube ich auch
eingebaut und für die anderen großen Ideas auch, aber ich bin da Ansicht, am besten
kann man Git immer noch auf der Kommando-Zeile verwenden, weil das einfach die Tools sind,
wofür es ursprünglich dafür entwickelt wurden und viele Sachen unter der Haube kann man
auch nur mit den Kommando-Zeilen-Tools machen, so aber vorher, jetzt nochmal eine Frage an
euch, wie gesagt wir benutzen kein GitHub Direct, wir benutzen GitHub Clone, bei mir
die Lokal, das ist die Frage, ich hab schon einen installiert, den können wir gleich
verwenden oder wollen wir uns mal einen selbst installieren, ich habe hier meinen Server
stehen um die Ecke im Schrank und da könnten wir uns schnell einen Git Tiga, oder wie ihr
man das ausspricht, Webfronten dann drauf installieren, dass man auch mal so sieht wie
simpel das eigentlich geht, sich quasi so ein privates GitHub zu installieren, wohlgemerkt
nochmal an der Stelle, man braucht kein Webfrontend um Git zu verwenden, ich kann auch ohne Probleme
rein bei mir Lokal Stream, ich kann auch rein bei mir Lokal Git verwenden und machen und
tun, ich brauche dazu kein Webfrontend wie Git haben, jetzt halt die Frage, soll ich
erst mal eine Teamarkt Session, Teamarkt setzt irgendwie meine Terminal Variable nicht richtig,
kann das sein, kann ja nix werden, wie dem auch sein, ich verbinde mich jetzt mal auf
meinen Server und installiere uns einen lokalen GitHub Klon, den wir dann verwenden, was ist
der Unterschied zwischen Git Tiga und Gox, Gox, Git Tiga ist ein Gox Fork, das ist alles
Go programmiert und alles ziemlich ähnlich, es gibt eigentlich zwei, ich sag mal drei
größere GitHub Klone, das ist einmal Gox, das ist einmal Bitbucket und das ist einmal
GitLab, wenn ich jetzt noch richtig tippen könnte, das sind so, oder sagen wir mal,
wenn man das hier noch mitnimmt, vier, das sind so die vier größten GitHub Klone zum
selbst installieren, GitLab ist mit Abstand am ekligsten und kompliziertesten zu installieren,
das ist eine Ruby und Rails Anwendung, funktioniert auch wunderbar, aber das zu installieren ist
echt immer ein riesen Akt, Bitbucket gibt es auch zum lokalen installieren, ist von Atlassian,
das ist im Business Bereich relativ beliebt und Gox, wahrscheinlich spricht man das Go
GS oder so aus, ist auch sowas in der Richtung, so ein GitHub Klon, aber wir installieren
uns jetzt erstmal lokal Git Tiga, wie man das auch immer schreibt, das ist ziemlich
simpel, ich werde jetzt einfach mal einen Container anlegen auf meinem Server, installieren
das und dann verwenden wir das im restlichen Stream, bei uns wird Bitbucket verwendet,
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es Bitbucket nicht Gitbucket heißen soll, Bitbucket ist
im Business Umfeld tatsächlich sehr beliebt, weil Bitbuckets kommt von Atlassian und Atlassian
stellen ganz viele Business Zeug Software her, so Ticket Systeme und Wikis und so, wo Business
Leute draufstehen, deswegen ist im Business Umfeld Bitbucket relativ beliebt, so, ja,
schlaue ich mich mal auf meinem Server ein, der den ganz unauffälligen Namen POGCHAMP.INTERN
trägt, jetzt muss ich aber aufpassen, was ich mache, denn ich will ja hier kein Mist,
Mist auf meinem Server treiben, sonst ist alles weg, aber vorher muss ich mal, wie kommt
man TMAX Set, weil es geht mir auf den Sack, dass ich keine Farben habe, aha, kann man
Default Terminal umstellen, Default Terminal Option, ja, das machen wir doch mal, meine
TMAX Conf sieht außer ein bisschen Farben, wir können auch mal irgendwann uns noch eine
Runde TMAX und so die grundlegenden Kommando Zeilen, Tools und sowas angucken, was habe
ich mir jetzt verkehrt gemacht, wie ist denn die richtige, achso Set, wie ging das nochmal,
Set, achso geht das, ok, weißt du, Stack Overflow Driven Programming, so ging das, ups,
ja, jetzt haben wir glaube ich auch, jetzt haben wir auch ordentliche Farbe und alles,
so, loggen wir uns mal auf meinem Server ein und ich schreibe jetzt mein Passwort nicht
hin, sodass man das sehen kann, so und wir legen uns jetzt mal einen neuen Container
an, das mache ich mit LXT, das kann man auch mit Docker oder sonst was in der Richtung
machen, mit Docker ist es ein bisschen einfacher, da gibt es schon komplett fertige Docker Container,
die startlich einfach und da läuft dann irgendwie in Setze X beliebiges Git Webfrontend ein,
wir legen uns jetzt einfach mal selbst einen an, wie nennen wir denn den, Launch, so nennen
wir ihn nicht, wir müssen ihn irgendwie Twitch Emotes mäßig nennen, habe ich schon einen
gebated Container, ich glaube nicht, gebated, heißt der jetzt, so, jetzt haben wir uns noch
einen Container angelegt, da brauche ich jetzt natürlich noch ein Netzwerk Interface und
jetzt können wir uns verbinden in das Ding, so, das wird unser Git Frontend Server, ich
kann mir vorstellen, das ist jetzt ziemlich verwirrend, was ich hier treibe, weil, weiß
nicht, wie sehr verbreitet Linux Container und sowas sind, zumindest ist es eigentlich
vollkommen wurscht, weil ich will ja nur mal temporär mir einen Git Webfrontend installieren,
ist eigentlich egal, was ich genau mache, so, install, wo haben die hier ihre Install Anleitung,
Git Grundlagen gebated, install, install from binary, das ist ok, das ist Go, Go ist das
immer relativ simpel, da kann man einfach was runterladen, starten und gut ist, ah, ich
komme nicht ins Internet, weil ich keine IP habe, dann starten wir mal den Container
neu, dann kriege ich wahrscheinlich eine IP, so, also habe ich eine IP, jetzt kann ich
auch den Gram runterladen, wir machen da jetzt gar keine großen Sperenzien, wir lassen es
jetzt unter root laufen und gut ist, ich müsste jetzt von meinem Rechner aus eigentlich gebated.internal
auflösen können, geht nicht, warum geht das nicht, normalerweise sollte man DHCP Server,
sobald sich, sobald sich den Server eine DHCP IP zieht, sollte der den eigentlich eintragen,
macht er aber nicht, aber naja, es gibt schlimmeres, warum macht er sowas nicht, was soll das,
muss ich mal nachgucken, ist aber auch egal, wir können auch die IP von dem Ding nehmen,
kann es sein, dass man Container mit einer VM gleichsetzen kann, so ungefähr, es gibt
halt einen gravierenden Unterschied, dass eine VM quasi die Hardware komplett virtualisiert,
emuliert, wie auch immer man das will und ein Container nicht, also ein Container, wenn
du in einem Container ein Programm startest, ist das im Endeffekt kein Unterschied, so
wie wenn du das auf dem Server direkt starten würdest, bloß das noch so ein bisschen Sandbox
drum herum ist, VM läuft ja komplett in einer eigenen virtuellen Rechner, der mit dem Hostsystem
nichts mehr zu tun hat, so würde ich mal die Unterschiede beschreiben zwischen Container
und VM, was ich echt merkwürdig finde, dass normalerweise geht das immer, sobald ich einen
neuen Container anlege, zack, ist der im DNS drinne, ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht funktioniert
jetzt, weil ich meine, weil man selber funktioniert es ja auch, kann das sein, dass ich noch den,
dass ich noch Hostname setzen muss, das könnte tatsächlich sein, dass ich noch Hostname und
Zeug setzen muss, probieren wir das nochmal aus, Hostname, Ups, Hostname, eh, umgedreht,
muss man das nochmal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert, strage es nebenbei nochmal so ein, so, gut,
besser wieder, jetzt gehts, sehr schön, es löst das auch auf, jetzt haben wir hier eine
ordentliche Domain, die brauchen wir zwar nicht, aber sie ist schöner, ok, haben wir
den Krampel runtergeladen, haben wir, ah ja, haben wir, Moment, das ist eine total alte
Version, die will ich nicht, Downloadpage, kurze Frage Max, wie findest du World War
2 bisher, also wie gesagt, ich fand es in der Beta schon nicht schlecht, aber es steht
und fällt damit, wie das auf dem PC sich entwickelt mit Spielerzahlen und Cheater, der Milchmann
hat sich die Linux-Krone geklonen, sehr schön, so, haben wir hier lang genug jetzt rumgemacht,
jetzt gucken wir uns mal, wirklich Git an, keine Webfront eins, so, jetzt gehen wir mal
auf unseren lokalen GitHub-Klonen, tubated.internal.port3000, warum port3000, weil es da steht, zack, so,
wir brauchen eine Lokale, wir benutzen immer SQL-Datenbank-Lokal, nein, nicht immer SQL,
SQLite-Datenbank-Lokal, Domain is eternal, tubated.internal, so, Admin-Account wird jetzt
über Max, Passwort, ganz furchtbar komplex, adds, was weiß ich, null, einfach komm, egal,
okay, oh, brauchen wir nicht, wieder neues repo an, so, das ist jetzt nicht GitHub, das
ist jetzt bei mir lokal installierte Version von, denkst, wie heißt, Git, Gitia, äh,
Richie, äh, der Richie fragt, was ist Git, denn überhaupt, und wozu verwendet man es,
Git ist ein Versionsverwaltungssystem für, ich lass den Service als Routel auf und sieh
wo, genau, scheiß drauf, das ist jetzt nur zum, zum angucken, nicht für produktiven
Einsatz, ähm, das ist ein Versionsverwaltungssystem, das heißt, damit kann man seinen Source-Code
verwalten und jetzt natürlich die große Frage, was hat man davon, wenn man seinen Source-Code
damit verwaltet, man kann zum Beispiel einfacher Fehler suchen, wann Fehler aufgetreten sind,
man kann gucken, quasi, wann welche Sachen hinzugekommen sind, ab wann was kaputt ist,
man kann sich die Versionshistorie angucken, ähm, wenn man was verkackt, ist es relativ
einfach, auf einen funktionierenden Stand zurückzugehen, wenn man mit mehreren Leuten
an einem Projekt arbeitet, ist das sehr schön, um das dann am Ende, die Ergebnisse zu kombinieren
und sowas, also, wenn man nicht gerade allein an irgendwas werkelt, ist es fast schon Pflicht
und selbst wenn man allein an was werkelt, hat das schon seine Vorteile, weil zum Beispiel,
ich mein, mal angenommen, man hat jetzt hier irgendwas, irgendwas programmiert, ja, irgendwas
langes, was auch immer, das ist jetzt irgendwie meine tolle Programmiersprache, so und ich
hab jetzt ganz viel programmiert, so, einen ganzen Tag lang hab ich das hier jetzt programmiert,
das war ganz furchtbar schwer und ich mein, jeder kennt's, dass man dann sagt, fuck, irgendwas
hab ich jetzt kaputt gemacht, woran lag das denn jetzt noch mal und dann fängst du an,
hier die große Steuerung Z-Orgie zu machen, bis zu einem Stand vor ein paar Stunden, wo
du weißt, dass es funktioniert, dann änderst du wieder was und dann vertippst du dich und
kommst nicht mehr zurück und hast zwei Stunden Arbeit verloren, das Problem hat man mit einer
Versionsverwaltungssystem nicht mehr, wenn man es dann ordentlich verwendet, weil dann
macht man sich einfach, dann committet man einfach seine Changes, die man zu einem Stand,
wo man weiß, dass sie funktioniert haben und wenn man es dann verkackt, dann kann ich immer
noch sagen, ok, ich geh jetzt auf den Stand zurück, wo es funktioniert hat, so, legen
wir mal ein neues Repo an, ja, sowas hatte jeder wahrscheinlich schon, Stream, das brauchen
wir nicht, Create Repo, der hat's nicht so hier mit Domains richtig setzten, das stimmt
nicht wirklich, oder, kann man das jetzt noch ändern, die Domain ist, ja die Domain ist
nicht in Tunnel, der hätte sagen sollen, man soll den FQDN angeben, Kackprogramm, äh,
nervt mich jetzt schon, ich weiß jetzt, wo wir in welchem Ort wir sind, machen wir den
ganzen Scheiß nochmal, so und wir machen jetzt wirklich mal so ganz simple Sachen, wie gesagt
wir legen uns jetzt ein Repo an, dann machen wir mal ein paar Branches, dann machen wir
ein paar Commits, dann merken wir das ganze, ähm, also eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich
basic, machen wir die ganzen Kram nochmal, weil's komische Sachen gemacht hat, ok, dann
ist es jetzt, schreiben wir das halt mal komplett hin, äh, Admin Accounts, hochkomplexes Passwort,
so, so, jetzt legen wir nochmal unser Repo an für heute, was wir heute verwenden, nennen
wir mal Stream, blablabla, create, jetzt stimmt das ganze auch, so, hier stehen jetzt schon
so ein paar Standard, die Musik ist irgendwie, oh, wupp wupp wupp, wupp wupp wupp, so, das
ist jetzt quasi unser Fake GitHub, mit unserem Repo drauf, das Repo nennt sich Stream, das
wird auf GitHub nicht so viel anders aussehen, ähm, in dem Repo ist noch überhaupt nichts
drinne, deswegen legen wir uns jetzt ein neues Repo an und pushen da initial mal eine leere
Readme Datei rein, das machen wir nicht so wie es da steht, sondern wir machen das jetzt
eine Reihe nach, ähm, ich geh jetzt erstmal in meinen Repo Ordner, das muss man nicht
machen, aber ich mach das immer ganz gerne, ich hab in meinem Heimatverzeichnis immer
einen Ordner, der nennt sich Repos, und da sind meine ganzen unterschiedlichen Git Repos
drinne, die ich von irgendwo geklont hab, oder selbst angelegt hab, ähm, das sind, irgendwie
geht mir die Musik heute echt auf den Sack, ich mach jetzt mal aus, hat da, hat jemand
einen guten Link zu irgendwelcher entspannender Hintergrundmusik, da klone ich meistens meine
ganzen Repos rein, da weiß ich wenigstens wo sie sind, auf der Arbeit sind da wahrscheinlich
schon alle 70 Repos oder sowas in der Richtung drinne, so, ich hab sogar schon ein Repo vorhin
angelegt, ich lösch das jetzt aber nochmal, ähm, Stream, ein Repo legt man ganz einfach
an, indem man in den Ordner reingeht und sagt Git Init, ich glaube man kann auch sagen Git
Init Name, geht auch, also man kann auch sagen Git Init Stream, jetzt haben wir ein leeres
Git Repo angelegt, wo nichts drinne ist, der auch noch keine Comments hat und noch gar
nichts, es ist einfach ein leeres Git Repo, ich glaub euch nix hier im Chat, was auch immer,
wenn da einer schon was vorschlägt und mit Kappa dahinter, da weiß ich schon, das klappt
wahrscheinlich eher nicht mit Entspannungsmusik, komm wir machen wieder hier, wie hieß er,
ähm, Piano, wie hieß der Typ der, das war doch echt entspannt, das hatten wir doch schon
mal vor ner Weile an, außerdem haben es die Japaner halt übelst drauf, ja das ist echt
entspannt, aber es ist ein bisschen leise, ja das ist nice, so, ähm, wir legen jetzt
einfach mal ne leere Readme Datei an, in unserem Repo, wir schreiben da nix rein, wir können
da reinschreiben Hallo oder irgendwie sowas, so, und jetzt haben wir gerade ein leeres
Git Repo angelegt und die erste Datei drin erstellt, das muss keine Readme Datei sein,
das kann alles mögliche sein, das kann auch direkt euren schon vorhandener Source Code
sein, den ihr da jetzt einfach reinkopiert, was aber wichtig ist, sobald man irgendwas
geändert hat und Git mitteilen möchte, dass man diesen Stand benutzen will beziehungsweise
diesen Stand jetzt, ähm, nen, ja, was man denn, nen Name geben will oder den Stand committen
will, weil so heißt der Befehl letztendlich auch, macht man Git commit und am Anfang wird
er jetzt meckern, dass ich noch keine Lautstärke, Lautstärke, am Anfang wird er jetzt natürlich
meckern, dass ich noch keine, keinen Namen und, und Gedöns und Zeug gesetzt hab, ähm,
aber so ist das halt, ähm, ja, und er wird wahrscheinlich meckern, dass es nichts zu
committen gibt, richtig, wir pushen jetzt einfach mal ne leere Datei ins Repo rein und dann
gucken wir uns das Ganze im Detail nochmal an. So, ich muss, äh, Name setzen, meine E-Mail
Adresse ist maxandlocalhost und mein Name ist max, fertig. So, ähm, und jetzt kann
ich den Stand nehmen, den ich hier drinne hab und, ähm, quasi erst mal zu meinem Remote
Server schieben und sobald ich das gemacht hab, wird dann hier dann auch der ganze Krempel
drin auftauchen. Hier wird gehackselt, ja, genau, Silent Pain. Äh, Oxygen Event, was
meinst du? Für was ist das ganze Programmierzeug? Ja, zum Programmieren, oder was meinst du?
Äh, Swiss fragts, Max, auf wieviel Gigahertz ist dein i7-8700k? Auf 5 ist der. Mittlerweile.
Auf 5 Gigahertz. Max, hast du schon mal versucht einen Cheat für ein Game zu programmieren?
Nö. So, ähm, wobei das machen wir nicht, wir machen das so wie die das geschrieben
haben. Wat? Ich darf nicht drauf zugreifen, warum? Ah, ich darf wahrscheinlich nicht
drauf zugreifen, weil ich, ich muss wahrscheinlich noch mein SSH Key, mein SSH Key noch hier
irgendwie hinterlegen, irgendwo, wo auch immer, der genau hin muss. Ist natürlich jetzt
ein bisschen doof. Ja, ich hätt mir das vielleicht ein bisschen besser überlegen sollen am Anfang,
wie wir das machen, aber gleich, gleich haben wir's. Äh, wahrscheinlich new settings, SSH
Key, geht das so? Ich hab das Tool noch nie verwendet. Sehr schön, hat funktioniert.
So, in dem Zustand, wie unser Repo jetzt ist, vergesst einfach alles, was wir gerade gemacht
haben, in dem Zustand, wie unser Repo jetzt ist, sieht es normalerweise so aus, wenn man
es sich von GitHub geklonet hat. Also sprich, man hat, ähm, das können wir jetzt auch mal
machen. Wo ist es denn hin? Genau, jetzt ist die ReadMe drinne und sonst nix. So, wir löschen
das Repo jetzt nochmal lokal und eine Sache wird man dann schon sehen, wenn ich lokal
irgendwas an meinem Repo mache, hat das logischerweise überhaupt keine Auswirkungen drauf, was mit
dem Stand irgendwo anders passiert. Und das ist eine ganz wichtige Sache, die man sich
bei Git erstmal standardmäßig merken muss, ähm, bevor ich nicht was pushe, es ist alles
nur lokal, auch wenn da lokal irgendwie Remote dran steht oder sowas in der Richtung. Das
ist vollkommen wurscht bei Git, es ist alles nur lokal, das muss man sich merken. Also
man kann nichts irgendwie kaputt machen, das ist nicht wie bei SVN oder sowas in der Richtung,
wo man quasi halb immer mit einem Bein auf dem Server ist. Bei Git ist alles standardmäßig
lokal, bis man explizit sagt, man schiebt es irgendwo hin. Auch wenn es auf den ersten
Blick nicht so aussieht. So, also wenn jemand schon mal auf GitHub war, ähm, oder falls
irgendjemand sich jetzt mal die Linux-Körne klonen will oder sowas in der Richtung, ähm,
ja, Patrick, ich hause mir ein Git-Tee, oder wie das Ding hieß. Ist einfacher zu installieren
als GitLab. Man kann auch GitLab verwenden, ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Ding. So. Z-Frames,
das guck ich mir nachher mal irgendwann an. So, ähm, also vollkommen unabhängig von dem,
was wir jetzt gemacht haben, der erste Schritt, wo viele Leute erstmal mit Git in Berührung
kommen, ist, wenn sie sich irgendwo in ein Repo klonen wollen. Also sprich, den Source-Code
beispielsweise von GitHub, hier jetzt von Visual Studio Code oder von irgendwelchen Projekten
wollen sie sich lokal bei ihnen auf dem Rechner klonen, editieren vielleicht, vielleicht
auch noch was einreichen, dann wieder bei dem jeweiligen Projekt. Aber das erste, womit
Leute in Kontakt kommen, ist wahrscheinlich Git-Clone. Und Git-Clone ist auch genauso
simpel, wie es aussieht. Man schreibt einfach hin, Git-Clone, und dann die Url, was man
sich klonen will, und dann hat man lokal einen Ordner von dem jeweiligen Repo, was
man sich geklont hat. Also easy. Das ist auch noch nicht wirklich das Komplizierte. Das
kriegt glaube ich jeder noch hin. Das kann man auch mit allen möglichen Sachen machen.
Ich könnte jetzt auch beispielsweise sagen, jetzt sind wir hier auf GitHub, ich könnte
auch sagen, hier, ich will mir jetzt einfach mal Visual Studio Code klonen. Das funktioniert,
kann ich machen. Git-Clone, bam, das man sieht schon, das dauert ein bisschen länger,
das ist auch ein bisschen größer. Funktioniert, ist überhaupt kein Ding. Ähm, wirklich interessant
wird es natürlich erst, wenn man was editiert, bzw. wenn man was entwickelt. Und noch interessanter
wird es, wenn mehrere Leute dran editieren und dran entwickeln. Was man eben schon ganz
gut gesehen hat, ist die Musik wieder ein bisschen laut, ne? Ach wobei, nicht, das passt.
Aber ein bisschen. Was man eben schon ganz gut gesehen hat, ich meine, ich konnte lokal
das Repo löschen und es war Remod noch da. Das heißt, jeder der an irgendeinem Projekt
mitarbeitet und das Repo sich geklont hat, hat lokal erstmal ne Kopie vom kompletten
Repo. Wirklich komplett, mit allem dabei. Ähm, das hat natürlich den riesen Vorteil,
es geht auch nicht so leicht mal was verloren. Selbst wenn der Server, auf dem das ganze
mal gehostet war, oder gehostet ist, wenn der verreckt, also wenn morgen jetzt beispielsweise
GitHub abraucht, weiß ja nicht, könnte sein, so Ruby on Rails Abwendung, ähm, wenn morgen
GitHub abraucht, ist der Source Code von Visual Studio Code garantiert nicht verloren, weil
sich mindestens 5000 Leute dieses Repo bisher geforkt haben, äh, und sich wahrscheinlich
noch viel viel mehr Leute dieses Repo mal lokal bei sich irgendwo hingeklont haben.
Und das ist auch eines der wichtigsten Unterschiede zu ähm, anderen Versionsverwaltungssystemen
wie, äh, wie SVN oder sowas, dass man eben erstmal hauptsächlich lokal arbeitet und
erst dann pusht, bzw. sich neue Changes pullt. Und man kann Git nach Herzenlust ausprobieren
bei sich lokal, man kann nichts kaputt machen. Es wäre ja auch ziemlich bescheuert, ich meine,
ich hab mir jetzt hier den Source Code von Visual Studio Code geklont und ich lösche
jetzt einfach mal alles. Bäm! Es wäre ganz schön bescheuert, wenn es jetzt bei Microsoft
gelöscht wäre, ne? Ist es nicht, es ist nur bei mir lokal gelöscht. Ok, gehen wir mal
wieder in unser Test Repo. Wenn man jetzt was entwickelt, irgendwas kleines, ja? Irgendeine
Mini-Anwendung. Wir können jetzt ja mal hier im, im, wir machen irgendwie mal so ein Mini-Bashed
Crypt, was, was irgendeinen Mist ausgibt oder so. Ähm, dann commiten wir da ein paar Änderungen
rein und dann pushen wir das und merchant das und schauen uns das mal in der Ruhe, äh,
in Ruhe an. Ähm, ich muss sagen, mir fällt es ein bisschen schwierig, das so zu erklären
von Anfang an, dass das alles nachvollziehbar ist, weil ich benutze das schon eine ganze
Weile und ich kümmere mich eigentlich hauptsächlich um der, auf der Arbeit, um unsere Git Repos,
um unsere Software Repos. Und viele Sachen, die ich wahrscheinlich einfach so mache, leuchten
euch nicht so großartig ein, könnte ich mir vorstellen. So, ähm, ja, es gibt ein paar
wichtige Sachen, die man auch wissen muss, wo immer einige Leute durcheinander kommen.
Es gibt, ähm, wenn man sich ein Repo geklont hat, gibt es standardmäßig erstmal zwei
Sachen, oder meistens zwei Sachen standardmäßig. Ähm, die Quelle, von der man sich das Repo
geklont hat, ist standardmäßig eingetragen hier als Remote-Server. Der nennt sich Origin,
das Ding heißt immer Origin. Origin ist immer der Server, von dem ich mir mein Repo geklont
habe, aber das muss nicht so heißen. Das kann irgendwie heißen. Origin ist einfach nur Name
und sie mussten ja irgendeinen Default-Name vergeben. Ja, ich glaube, der Nightbot ist
abgeschmiert, Sebaro, stimmt's? Aber die haben gestern auch schon ganz schön rumgeleckt.
Vielleicht ist es einfach kaputt. Das muss man sich merken, ähm, Origin ist einfach nur
ein Name. Das sehe ich auch auf der Arbeit ganz oft, dass viele Leute denken, Origin
wäre irgendein Git-Befehl oder sowas. Und das hat auch nichts mit Origin von EA zu tun,
sondern es ist einfach gemeint, von da hast du es halt ursprünglich geklont, dein Repo.
Aber man kann auch mehrere Remote-Repos haben und dort Sachen reinpushen. Also ich könnte
beispielsweise hier meinen lokalen Server haben, wo halt dieses Frontend beispielsweise
drauf läuft, plus noch einen Rechner von einem Kumpel, der bei mir mitentwickelt, oder noch
einen Server in irgendeinem Rechenzentrum, auf dem die Anwendung wirklich drauf läuft.
Und die kann ich mir alle als Remotes eintragen und bei Push und Pull verwenden. Aber dass
das Ding Origin heißt, ist vollkommen egal, ist einfach nur ein Name. So, und was man
auch wissen muss... Hä, Siebauer, was? Hä, verstehe ich nicht. Was man auch noch wissen
muss, dass man standardmäßig eine Branche hat, der Master heißt, das ist auch einfach
nur, weil er ja irgendwas nach dem Klonen anzeigen muss. Und dann nimmt er einfach standardmäßig
Master, wenn es ihn gibt. Das ist nichts, was wirklich so heißen muss. Viele Leute denken,
die Dinger müssen Origin oder müssen Master heißen, ist vollkommen egal. So, also wir
haben jetzt wirklich ein ziemlich leeres, quasi nur mit einer Datei befüllendem repo.
Und in dieser Datei steht einfach nur Hallo drin. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal die History angucken,
sehen wir, es gibt genau ein Comment, das ist von mir und das ist vor, was weiß ich, 10
Minuten entstanden und ist offensichtlich das erste. Was man bei Git wissen muss, was
ist, oder so die Grundlagen, mit denen man früher oder später in Berührung kommt, sind,
was sind Comments, was sind Branches, vielleicht noch was sind Tags und was gibt es denn sonst
noch interessantes, was sind Remotes. Aber am wichtigsten ist eigentlich am Anfang mal
zu wissen, was ist ein Branch und was ist ein Comment. Wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas anfange
zu entwickeln, so beispielsweise, ich will jetzt ein ganz tolles Bash-Skript programmieren,
was irgendwas tolles macht. Ich hatte ja einer eine glorreiche Idee, was das tolles machen
könnte. Oder machen wir es anders. Komm, wir einfach alles in Mastercommenten. Ja, das
ist finde ich sogar, äh, Patrick, das ist finde ich sogar legitim, wenn man das macht,
wenn man alleine daran entwickelt. Wir machen das jetzt mal, das repo machen wir jetzt mal
auf mit Visual Studio Code, dass man bisschen GUI-mäßig, dass man sieht, dass das überhaupt
nichts mit den eigentlichen Programmen zu tun hat, was man verwendet. Ähm, äh, Open
Folder. Plende das standardmäßig Readmees aus, das Ding, oder was? Lull. Ein Skript,
das den Sinn des Lebens bricht. Jawoll, das können wir machen. Also, wir fangen jetzt,
wir fangen jetzt mal an ein ganz tolles Bash-Skript zu programmieren. Ähm, und danach kommitten
wir das in unser Git-Repo, machen Änderungen und Dinger. Ich glaube, dann wird das wahrscheinlich
auch alles ein bisschen, bisschen greifbarer. Wie macht mir die neue Datei-Steuerung N. So,
das wird jetzt, äh, unser ganz tolles Bash-Skript. Die Schrift ist riesengroß. Echo. Hallo Twitch.
Ups, ich hab einen Punkt zu viel. So. Und, wenn man sich das jetzt mal anguckt in unserem
Git-Repo, äh, Hasenkürze fragt, was ist deiner Meinung nach die Entwicklungsumgebung
der Zukunft? Eclipse Intellijane Visual Studio kommt drauf an, für was. Also, ich denke,
unter Windows und für Microsoft-Gedöns, was, also sowas wie C-Sharp oder, oder VisualBasic.net
oder solche Dinger. Ich bin im falschen Ordner gelandet. Echt? Ne, ich glaub, ich glaub,
das passt. Ähm, ne, ich bin im falschen Ordner. WTF, hä? Ach, ich bin im falschen, ja, ich
bin wirklich im falschen Ordner. Lul. Da ist es. Da ist jetzt auch das drinne. Naja,
um nochmal zur Entwicklungsumgebung zurückzukommen. Jetzt ist auch die ReadMe drinne, ja. Jetzt
funktioniert das Ganze auch. Ähm, unter Windows wird es weiter Visual Studio bleiben. Für
JavaScript seh ich, also für JavaScript und Webzeug, seh ich ehrlich gesagt Visual Studio
Code ziemlich weit vorne und ist auch recht beliebt. Für C++ find ich den Cute Creator
ziemlich gut. Aber man kann auch, wenn man Windows Zeug entwickelt, das ohne Problem
mit Visual Studio machen. Und für Java und solche Sachen, ich hasse Eclipse. Ich, Eclipse
ist wirklich, da musst du instant kotzen, wenn man es benutzen muss. Ähm, wenn, dann
verwende ich Intelli, war das IntelliJ? IntelliJ, ID, genau, ja, das Ding. Für Groovy und solche
Sachen. Aber, ähm, für Webgeschichten ist Visual Studio Code zur Zeit sehr angesagt.
So, jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich irgendwie ziemlich n Mist gemacht hier. So, ähm, wir
haben jetzt angefangen unser tolles Bash Script zu programmieren. Das macht nicht sonderlich
viel. Das macht aktuell noch gar nix. Außer auszugeben, hallo Twitch. Nein, das neue Assassin's
Creed hab ich mir noch nicht angeguckt. Ähm, jetzt will ich aber vielleicht, dass da der
Patrick oder der Sebaro oder irgendjemand dran mitarbeiten können. Und deswegen muss
ich jetzt erstmal mein tolles neues Bash Script comitten und pushen, dass das irgendjemand
anderes verwenden könnte. Und man sieht hier schon, dass Git da grundsätzlich das erstmal
unterscheidet zwischen Dateien, die es kennt und Dateien, die es nicht kennt. Wenn ich
eine neue Datei angelegt hab, dann sagt Git erstmal standardmäßig, ähm, selbst wenn
ich jetzt sage, ich will comitten, sagt Git erstmal standardmäßig, ne, kenn ich net,
das ist das. Wenn ich mir mit Git Status angucke, was gerade im Repo so passiert, ähm, sehe
ich, dass ich untracked Files drinne hab. Warum sind die Files untracked? Naja, ich
hab's gerade eben erst angelegt. Und da muss ich initial einmal für jede Datei, die neu
ist, man kann das auch umgehen, ja, man kann das auch einfacher machen, ähm, die muss
ich erstmal hinzufügen. Muss ich erstmal sagen, Git, kümmere dich um die Datei in
diesem Ordner. Nur weil ich hier in dem Git Ordner drinne bin, heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass sich Git standardmäßig für jede Datei zuständig fühlt. So, wenn ich jetzt ein Git
add auf die Datei gemacht hab, dann sehe ich schonmal bei dem nächsten Git Status, change
to be committed, also sprich, Git kennt die Datei jetzt, ähm, und ich kann mir jetzt
auch mit Git diff, ne, mit Git, äh, fuck, wie ging das, staged, ähm, kann ich mir auch
angucken, was Git jetzt committen würde. Und nun kann ich auch sagen, Git commit, und
jetzt, ich kann das immer nur betonen, die meisten Leute halten sich nicht dran, oder,
ähm, sind da einfach nur zu faul für, ich muss sagen, bin ich auch oftmals, ne gescheite
Commit Message reinzuschreiben. Das muss nix langes sein, aber was ne schlechte Commit
Message ist, ist zum Beispiel das hier. Wenn ich an jedem Projekt arbeite, und selbst wenn
ich nur alleine dran arbeite, dann hab ich spätestens in zwei Tagen keine Ahnung mehr,
was ich hier bitteschön bei Fixes gemacht hab. Wenn ich da jetzt reinschreib, wenn
ich da wenigstens sowas reinschreib, Schreibfehler, fix, irgendwie, verschrieben, gefixt, ähm,
also, es hat seinen Vorteil, wenn man da irgendwas Sinnvolles reinschreibt, ja, äh, es reicht
schon, wenn wir irgendwie reinschreiben, hier edit new script oder irgendwas, da hat man
halbwegs noch nen Anhaltspunkt, was denn da, warum ist das eigentlich Nano? Warum ist das
Nano? Ich will, ich will kein Nano. Wie konnte man das nochmal ändern? Editor, ähm, wenn
man das hier so richtig schreibt, config, global, editor, oh, fuck, wie ging das jetzt,
das muss ich nachgucken. Was einem auch bei Git klar sein muss, man ist ziemlich oft unterwegs,
man kann entweder in der Gitman-Page gucken, wobei die Gitman-Page absolut wir geschrieben
ist, oder aber, man schaut einfach nach. Ah, hier, guck, git config global core editor
vim, das will ich machen. So, und wenn ich jetzt das nächste Mal was committe, dann geht
auch ein ordentlicher Editor auf und nicht Nano. So, was man jetzt hier schon sieht ist,
ich hab ein neues Skript angelegt, ähm, ich hab's commited, wenn ich jetzt in die history
gucke, ja, ja, Milchwein, ich sag ja Stack Overflow Driven Programming, wenn ich jetzt
in meine history gucke, also sprich, dort wo ich sehe, in welcher Reihenfolge was passiert
ist, dann seh ich auch, ok, es gab hier unten einmal mein initiales Comet und hier drüber
seh ich, ich hab ein neues Comet gemacht hier vor ein paar Minuten, wo ich ein neues Skript
hinzugefügt hab. Wenn ich's jetzt genau wissen will, aktuell ist es noch ziemlich übersichtlich.
Moment. Aktuell ist es noch ziemlich übersichtlich, es ist, sind zwei Comets in dem Repo und die
sind beide von mir. Ähm, wenn man sich jetzt mal beispielsweise von Visual Studio Code
die Comets anguckt, das sind beispielsweise 25.000 und von total vielen unterschiedlichen
Leuten. Wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal auf der Kommando-Zeile an, ich klon mir das Ganze
noch mal. Das ist ein Projekt, das ist, hat eine gute Größe, das ist nicht so riesengroß
wie der, wie jetzt irgendwie der Linux Kernel oder sowas. Na, eben war das Ganze aber auch
schon ein bisschen schneller. Hat das eben schon genau so lang gebraucht, den Krams zu
klonen, ging das nicht eben noch schneller? Ha. Ja gut, sobald, sobald das geklont ist,
gucken wir da mal in die Historie rein, da sehen wir, dass ich schon ein bisschen mehr
als war mir im Repo drin und da wird eine Sache auch schon mal gleich klar und zwar,
dass es sinnvoll ist, ordentliche Comet-Messages zu machen. Das ist jetzt nämlich ein Projekt,
wo 409 Leute schon mitgewirkt haben in 25.000 oder in knapp 26.000 Comets. Da wird es dann
schon ein bisschen schwieriger mit der Übersicht. Wenn wir jetzt hier mal ein Gitlog drinnen
machen, sehen wir nämlich auch, dass es sind von ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Leuten,
die da dran mitgearbeitet haben und wenn jetzt hier jeder reingeschrieben hätte, irgendwie
fix ist, dann wird es ganz schön kompliziert zu checken, was da eigentlich passiert ist.
Einmal wieder zurück zu unserem Noob-Repo, so ein Billig-Repo, das hat immer noch zwei
Comets drin und jetzt der große Unterschied zu Versionsverwaltungssystemen wie beispielsweise
SVN, ja doch, ich kann das Zeug nicht richtig, ich verdrehe da immer die Buchstaben, ich
verdrehe auch immer CVS und CSV und alles. Der große Unterschied zu quasi zentralen
Versionsverwaltungssystemen mit dem zentralen Server, was es ja so bei Git nicht gibt, ist,
ich habe jetzt eine neue Datei angelegt, ich habe jetzt diesen neuen Stand committed, habe
ich mit einer Commit-Message dabei, aber das ist nach wie vor nur lokal bei mir. Das muss
man wissen, das ist nur lokal, also sprich, wenn jetzt irgendjemand von euch sich hier
mein Repo klonen würde, würde er diese Änderung noch nicht sehen, obwohl sie committed sind,
das ist bei SVN komplett anders. Da ist Commit halt Commit. Und was ich jetzt machen muss,
dass das andere Leute auch benutzen können, bzw. um es halt zu irgendeinem anderen Server
zu schieben, achtmal mit Git push. Und hier ist es auch wichtig, dass man, auch wenn man
es nicht machen muss, ist es sinnvoll, hier immer die kompletten Optionen anzugeben.
Also quasi, was ich machen will ist, ich will Git benutzen, ich will meinen Stand woanders
hinschieben, Git push, jetzt muss ich angeben, wohin, in dem Fall Origin, Origin ist das Repo,
von dem ich geklonet habe, und jetzt, welcher Branch, was ein Branch ist, kommen wir gleich
noch dazu. So, wenn ich das mache, dann funktioniert das Ganze auch, und wenn ich jetzt hier refresche,
ist das auch da, mein Skript. Und wenn jetzt jemand von euch sich mein Repo geklonet hätte,
und Git pull macht, dann wird er die Änderung auch sehen. Warum ich das für wichtig halte,
hier immer alles komplett anzugeben. Man kann auch die Kurzfassung machen, Git push. Git
push funktioniert in 99% der Fälle ohne Probleme, weil Git mittlerweile relativ clever ist, und
bei Git push standardmäßig halt nur den Branch pusht, auf dem man drauf ist. Das war früher
nicht so. Früher war Git push das Standard, das die Fault verhalten so, dass alle Branches,
die man lokal hatte, gepusht wurden, und da hat man teilweise Sachen gepusht, die man
nicht pushen wollte. Ich hatte mal auf der Arbeit einen, der hat irgendwie 15 Branches
gepusht, die er sich mal irgendwann ausgecheckt hat, paar Änderungen drin ausprobiert hat,
und die wollte er eigentlich gar nicht pushen. Das war halt ein bisschen blöd für ihn. Der
Name Origin verwirrt mich. Origin ist der Default Name für die Quelle, von der man,
oder wie es der Patrick gerade sagt, von der Herkunft, von der Quelle, wo man geklont
hat. Das ist der Default Name des Servers, des Remotes, bei Git heißt das Remote, von
dem man geklont hat. Man kann das übrigens auch umbenennen. Ich kann auch Git remote
rename, wie ging das nochmal, wenn ich das noch richtig schreibe, Git remote rename,
Origin kann ich auch umbenennen in, zum Beispiel GitHub. Wenn ich mir das jetzt angucke, heißt
das überhaupt nicht mehr Origin. Wenn ich das jetzt nochmal machen würde, würde ich
sagen, das geht nicht, weil es das Remote Origin nicht mehr gibt. Jetzt müsste ich sagen,
Git push, Git hub master. Ist auch zu empfehlen, also wenn man mehrere Remotes hat, ist das
sinnvoll, die so zu benennen, dass man auf den ersten Blick gleich sieht, ja was wozu
gehört. Also das ist schon nicht verkehrt. Wir rename das nochmal, weil es ist ja gar
nicht GitHub, sondern es ist unser Fake GitHub. Es ist ja gar kein echtes GitHub, worauf
wir gepusht haben. Es ist ja nur unser Fake GitHub. Was wir jetzt gemacht haben ist, wir
haben ein neues Skript angelegt, wir haben das committed und wir haben das gepusht. Das
sind so die Standard-Basis-Operationen, die man immer braucht in Git. Ohne commiten, ohne
adden, ohne commiten, ohne pushen kommt man meistens nicht weit. Den Part mit pushen kann
man weglassen, wenn man nur lokal arbeitet. Man braucht sowas hier nicht, also sprich,
man muss sein Zeug nicht auf GitHub hochladen, das muss nicht sein. Man kann auch rein lokal
arbeiten. Ist auch nicht schlecht, wie gesagt, wenn man irgendwas klein im Bastelt und auch
gar nicht vorhat, das zu veröffentlichen. So, was gibt es jetzt als nächstes? Genau,
was sind Branches? Dazu muss man sich erstmal angucken, was sind commits. Wenn man in die
History guckt, was man, by the way, mit GitLog macht. GitLog hat übrigens sehr viele praktische
Optionen, beispielsweise das hier. Das hier ist ein Beispiel für typische Git-Optionen,
die sind nicht immer logisch. Also standardmäßig zeigt mir GitLog meine History an, also sprich
vom ältesten Commit zum neuesten Commit. Sag ich jetzt, GitLog name only als Option
zeigt es mir mehr an, allerdings noch die Namen, die sich geändert haben im jeweiligen
Commit der Datei, also welche Dateien sich im jeweiligen Commit geändert haben. Obwohl
die Option minus minus name only so aussieht, als würde es weniger anzeigen, nämlich nur
names only, macht es das nicht. Ganz viele Git-Commandos sind total wir, da muss man
sich mit abfinden. Und die Git-Man-Pages sind ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sonderlich
hilfreich. So mal hier als Beispiel. Guckt euch, lest euch mal, oder lesen wir uns mal
die ersten Sätze durch von GitPush. Man versteht nichts. Normalerweise ist eine Man-Page dafür
da, das soll einem das alles erklären, ein bisschen helfen, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
So, und die Hilfeseite für GitPush sagt mir, GitPush updates remote refs using local refs
while sending objects necessary to complete the given refs. Und jetzt kommt der beste
Satz überhaupt. You can make interesting things happen to a repository. Also, die Git-Man-Pages
sind legendär verwirrend. Ich würde gar nicht erst anfangen Git-Man-Pages zu lesen,
in dem Fall ist man wirklich mit einer Google-Suche und Stack-Overflow-Antworten meistens besser
dran. Also Git-Man-Pages sind wirklich sehr verwirrend. So, aber wenn wir uns jetzt nochmal
die History angucken, sehen wir, wir haben zwei Comets drinne, mein initiales Comet und
das, wo wir das Skript hinzugefügt haben. Jedes Comet bekommt in Git eine eindeutige
Hashtag-ID. Das ist ein Schar-Hash-Wert, wenn das interessiert. Und man sieht ja auch
teilweise ganz interessante Informationen dahinter. Zum Beispiel, welcher Remote-Stand eben auf
welchem Comet gerade ist und sowas, aber das ist jetzt erstmal egal. Wichtig ist, dass
jedes Comet einen eindeutigen Hashtag-Wert bekommt. Und dieser Hashtag-Wert oder diese
Comet-ID, nennen wir es mal Comet-ID, ist eines der Grundlagen, worauf Git basiert und
eines der wichtigsten Sachen. Man muss nicht wissen, was es ist, was es genau macht. Was
man wissen muss ist, jedes Comet hat weltweit sehr, sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich eine eindeutige
ID. Und ihr habt hier beispielsweise das Visual Studio Code-Repo gesehen, das hat schon 25.000
Comets. Und es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es kein Git-Repo gibt. Alle Git-Repos weltweit
zusammen. Dass es kein Comet gibt, das die gleiche ID hat. Und das ist auch wichtig,
weil bei Git ziemlich viel auf dieser Comet-ID basiert. Man braucht sie selbst relativ selten,
aber ich denke, das ist eine wichtige Sache, die einem klar sein muss. Weil, und das ist
auch eine wichtige Sache, man kann in Git die History, ich weiß, dass es geht, aber
ich sag's jetzt mal ein bisschen überspitzt, man kann in Git die History nicht ändern.
Man kann in Git die History nur umschreiben. Und wenn man in Git die History umschreibt,
ändert sich alles ab dem Zeitpunkt des Umschreibens. Weil die ganzen Comets basieren aufeinander.
Also sprich, diese Comet-ID, oder besser gesagt, diese Comet-ID, wird errechnet, aus dem der
es committet, aus der Uhrzeit, wann es committet wird, und ganz wichtig, aus der Comet-ID,
des Vorgänger-Comets. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt feststelle, ich hab hier unten irgendwann
mal Mist committet, was vorkommen wird, wie man das beheben kann, kommen wir auch noch
dazu. Wenn ich jetzt feststelle, ich hab hier unten irgendwann mal Mist committet in mein
Git Repo, dann kann ich das erstmal so pauschal nicht ändern. Das ist drinnen. Für immer
und ewig ist das in diesem Git Repo drinnen. Weil wenn ich jetzt hier hingehen würde,
und das ändern, würden sich alle Comets, die da drauf kommen, die nachvollen Comets,
wie sich die Comet-ID ändern. Was dazu führen würde, dass es für Git intern ein komplett
anderes Repo wäre, und alle, die irgendwie mitarbeiten an dem Repo, eine Historie haben
die nicht mehr zusammenpasst. Also die Historie in Git kann man nicht ändern. Man kann sie
nur umschreiben, und da sollte man auch aufpassen, was man macht. So, deswegen ist es auch nochmal
wichtig, dass es einem klar wird, dass man mit Git standardmäßig nur lokal arbeitet.
Das heißt, man kann, wenn man Mist committet hat, bevor man es pusht, das ändern, wie
man will, das wird nie jemand sehen, aber wenn man es gepusht hat, ist es da. Quasi
für immer. Das heißt, man muss sich überlegen, was man pusht. So, einmal angenommen, das
ist was, was viele Git-Tutorials beispielsweise viel später machen, aber ich finde, das ist
eigentlich eines der häufigsten Probleme, die Leute haben, die neu mit Git anfangen
oder die halt allgemein sich da, sich das gerade einfach ein bisschen angucken und das
lernen wollen. Wie kriege ich denn jetzt was wieder raus, wenn ich Mist committet habe?
Was, die Uhrzeit stimmt nicht? Ja, stimmt, die Uhrzeit stimmt nicht. Die Uhrzeit ist
total falsch. So, wie kriege ich denn jetzt wieder raus, wenn ich Mist committet habe?
Weil angenommen, ich habe hier jetzt irgendwas committet. Wir können uns mit git log minus
p, kann man sich anzeigen lassen, was committet wurde. Da sehen wir zum Beispiel, okay, ich
habe hier halt eine Datei committet mit diesem Inhalt und ich habe jetzt festgestellt, Mist,
eigentlich wollte ich schreiben, hallo stream und ich habe hallo twitch tv geschrieben.
Ich habe das jetzt gepusht, das ist da. Also man sieht das ja auch hier, wenn sich jetzt
irgendjemand geklont hätte, ja, dann hätte er jetzt halt das fehlerhafte Skript gehabt.
Was mache ich denn jetzt? Wie kriege ich denn das wieder raus? Und die einfache Antwort
ist gar nicht. Fixen und neu committen. Das ist der Weg in Git Fehler zu beheben. Also
selbst, wenn ich jetzt quasi theoretisch zurückrollen könnte, sollte ich das auf keinen Fall machen,
wenn ich es schon gepusht habe, weil danach sieht die history anders aus. So, und der
Gitweg, sowas zu fixen, ist im Prinzip ganz einfach. Man macht ein neues Comet. Also sprich,
ich rolle das jetzt nicht zurück und committe es nochmal mit dem korrekten Text, sondern
ich editiere das jetzt einfach zu dem, was ich eigentlich haben wollte, zwar hallo stream,
ich wollte nicht hallo twitch schreiben und jetzt committe ich das ganze einfach nochmal.
Jetzt Git Status eingeben, sagt der mir hier, guck mal, es hat sich was geändert. Visual
Studio Code sollte glaube ich auch irgendwie anzeigen, dass sich was geändert hat, macht
es nicht. Konnte das Visual Studio Code nicht, konnte das nicht anzeigen, dass sich was
Git technisch geändert hat. Keine Ahnung, ist ja auch wurscht. Ähm, wir machen das
jetzt mal hier alles Commando-Zeile. Genau, und jetzt mache ich ein neues Comet. Ich kann
das alles ein bisschen abkürzen. Die richtige Reihenfolge ist doch links im Git-Reiter.
Ah, das habe ich gesucht, ja quasi so ein Diff, was sich geändert hat. Aber sonderlich
schön ist es, schön ist es nicht. Ich kenne es von manchen Editoren, dass man hier vorne
so Plus und Minus angezeigt bekommt, wo sich was geändert hat. Ist aber auch egal. So,
die normale Reihenfolge, was zu committen ist ja, man edit es, ich mach das jetzt nicht,
man committet es und danach kann man es pushen oder das lokal lassen. Es gibt eine Kurzform
davon und die wird wahrscheinlich jeder verwenden, der häufiger Git verwendet, weil es einfach
nervig ist immer was zu adden. Man sagt einfach Git A minus M. Das heißt, committe alles,
alle Änderungen aus Dateien, die du kennst. In dem Fall, tolles Skript. Message nimmt
den Text, den ich hier hinten angebe, als Comet-Message. Ja, ich schaue jetzt irgendwie
mit Echo Text, was auch immer. So, wenn ich jetzt nachgucke, jetzt habe ich ein drittes
Comet, was den Fehler korrigiert hat, den ich vorher mit committet habe. Ich habe vorher
Mist committet, den habe ich jetzt wieder korrigiert. Und das ist der Weg, wie man das
in Git fixt. Standardmäßig rollt man nichts zurück, um was zu fixen. Also man rollt nichts
zurück, fixt es und committet es wieder. Man sagt, ok, der Fehler ist drinne, man ändert
ihn und macht ein neues Comet. Was ja auch irgendwo sinnvoll ist, weil überlegt euch
mal, ihr habt einen Fehler gepusht schon. Jemand anderes, der mitarbeitet, hat sich
das quasi ausgecheckt bei sich und hat jetzt die Datei mit dem Fehler und er hat vielleicht
da drin schon was editiert und ihr würdet es dann zurückrollen und dann pusht ihr eine
Datei, die so aussieht, die, quasi die Version, die er bei sich lokal hat, hätte es ja dann
nie gegeben in der History. Deswegen hat Git bei sowas Probleme, wenn man History ändert.
Da kommt es zu ganz wirren Ergebnissen und ich kann es nicht empfehlen, irgendwie die
History umzuschreiben. Es sei denn, es ist lokal, bevor man pusht. So. Wenn man noch
nicht gepusht hat, kann man sich das Leben ein bisschen einfacher machen. Wie gesagt,
normalerweise kommt das in Git-Tutorials immer viel später dran, aber ich finde das, wie
gesagt, das ist eines da, ja, eines, ein großes Problem, was viele Leute haben, die neue Git
verwenden. Wenn man noch nicht gepusht hat, kann man sich das Leben ein bisschen einfacher
machen. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt sage, Mist, meine Comet-Message ist falsch. Ich
wollte eigentlich nicht hinschreiben, Changed Echo Text, sondern Fixed Echo Text. Mist,
was mache ich denn jetzt? Soll ich jetzt ein neues Comet wirklich machen, wo ich dann
nochmal Fixed Echo, das ist doch, das ist doof. Das ist doof. Aber ich hab Glück, ich hab
noch nicht gepusht. Da sieht man hier unten auch an dem kleinen Pfeil von meiner, äh,
hier bash-git-sonsmaas-extension, äh, zschl-bash, äh, zsh-git-extension, ähm, dass ich quasi
lokal mehr Comets habe als Remote und ich die jetzt pushen könnte. Deswegen ist da
jetzt so ein Pfeil nach oben. Ähm, wenn ich jetzt einfach nur die Comet-Message ändern
will von meinem letzten Comet, wohlgemerkt, wenn ich noch nicht gepusht habe, sobald ich
gepusht habe, soll ich dieses Comet nie wieder anfassen, ähm, dann kann ich das so machen.
Und wir merken uns jetzt mal hier den Hash-Wert von diesem Comet, also quasi die weltweit
eindeutige Comet-ID. So, und hiermit kann ich jetzt das letzte Comet nochmal ändern.
So, und ich wollte schreiben Fixed-Echo-Text. Bam. Und jetzt kommt der Knackpunkt, die Comet-ID
hat sich geändert. Und die Comet-ID ist das, woran Git festmacht, ob es ein Comet eben
kennt oder nicht. Das heißt, wenn ich es schon gepusht hätte, hätte das jetzt geändert,
dass, äh, dann wäre Git verwirrt. Und alle, die es schon geklont hätten, wären auch verwirrt,
weil dann auf einmal was verschwindet, was schon mal da war. Und Git basiert darauf,
dass nichts verschwindet, sondern nur neue Sachen oben drauf kommen. Also das muss immer
so eine, die Historie muss immer quasi eins auf dem anderen aufsetzen und darf sich nicht
zwischendrin ändern. Ähm, aber nachdem ich das ja nur lokal bei mir hatte, hat das Remote
noch nie jemand gesehen. Sieht man ja auch, wenn ich hier meine Comments angucke, mein
neustes Comet hab ich noch überhaupt nicht gepusht. Jetzt hab ich es lokal bei mir gefixt
und jetzt kann ich das Ganze auch pushen und gut ist. Ähm, so und ich zeig euch jetzt
mal, was passiert, wenn ich das doch machen würde, die Historie ändern. Die haben was
genannt. GitHub, nee. Fake GitHub. So und dann gucken wir uns mal an, was Branches sind.
Comets sind da. Passt, jetzt hab ich es gepusht. So und wenn ich jetzt mich nicht dran halte
und sage, ich ändere was in meiner Historie, obwohl ich schon gepusht habe. Äh, ah guck
mal, der Eaxe ist da. Schon durch, mit was? Du meinst hier mit, äh, mit Kot? Ne, ich
hab heute noch gar nicht gespielt. Ich hatte heute noch keine Zeit. Aber wahrscheinlich
spiel ich nachher ne Runde. Komm, wir können nachher ne Runde, ähm, Dings hier War spielen
zusammen, wenn du willst. So und wenn ich jetzt jetzt doch mache, also sprich, wenn
ich jetzt doch die Historie ändere, obwohl ich schon gepusht hab, machen wir mal, ich
hab jetzt schon gepusht, jetzt sag ich, ach nee, ich würde doch gerne, dass mein, dass
meine letzte Comet Message wieder, äh, nicht Fixed Echo Text ist, sondern, äh, Changed
so Echo, Echo Text. Kann ich lokal machen. Jetzt zeigt es mir hier aber auch schon lokal
an, äh, die Historie passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Und wenn ich das jetzt versuche
zu pushen, dann sagt Git, geht nicht. Weil, Git hat als letztes Comet, das hier und bei
mir lokal will ich was pushen, wo es dieses Comet nicht gibt. Da sagt Git jetzt irgendwie,
Moment, das passt nicht zusammen. Äh, guckst du Overwatch World Cup Halbfinale? Ja, mach
ich. Das geht demnächst los, ne? Muss ich mal gucken. Ja, geht irgendwie in 20 Minuten
oder so los. Also die Basics mach ich, mach ich immer noch fertig. Äh, äh, Eax, ich
will Overwatch gucken fällt mir gerade ein. Ich wollt, wollt, äh, Dings die Overwatch
Halbfinale gucken. Ich kann's vergessen, dass das jetzt schon anfängt. So, und jetzt
sieht man schon, wenn ich das versuch zu pushen, geht nicht. So, und eine, die blödeste Sache,
die ich jetzt machen könnte, ich zeige euch nur mal, dass es geht, ist, wenn ich mit Force
pushe. Weil dann sag ich, Git, einfach scheiß drauf, was du denkst, mach's einfach. So,
und jetzt sieht man, ähm, wenn ich jetzt hier auf Comets gehe, jetzt ist das Comet
verschwunden und meins da. Jeder, der sich dieses Repo jetzt geklonet hätte, würde
einen Fehler bekommen, wenn er das nächste Mal versucht, was zu pullen. Das will man
nicht. Also, ganz einfach kann man sich merken, sobald was gepusht ist, wird das nicht mehr
angefasst. Nie wieder. Bis das Universum sich in Luft auflöst. Was gepusht wurde,
public, wird nie wieder angefasst. So. Das muss man jetzt mal so klar sagen. Monka Shake,
das macht man nicht, sowas. Weil dann haben alle, die dann dran mitarbeiten und man selbst
Probleme danach. Wie kann ich denn jetzt was rückgängig machen? Ähm, mal angenommen,
ich hab jetzt was größeres geändert und das war einfach kompletter Mist. Also sprich,
ähm, ich hab jetzt hier nen Sündagsfehler drinne. Ich hab jetzt hier nen Sündagsfehler
drinne. So. Ich hab ein neues Feature programmiert, was eigentlich, ähm, ganz toll ist und super
funktionieren sollte. So, und ich hab das jetzt committed, gepusht und jetzt stell ich fest,
Mist ich habe Mist gepusht. Ich hab nen Sündagsfehler drinne. Ja gut. In dem Fall ist es jetzt relativ
einfach. Ich mein, ich kann jetzt das genauso machen, wie ich es eben gezeigt hab. Ich
könnte hier reingehen, das löschen und nochmal neu committen. Aber, wenn wir jetzt mal von
ausgehen würden, realistischer gesehen, ähm, dieses neue Feature würde sich, sagen wir
mal, über 20 Dateien und 500 geänderte Zeilen erstrecken und ich, quasi derjenige, der sich
um das Repo kümmert, ja, dass das alles sauber und ordentlich läuft, hat gar keine Ahnung
von dem, was dieser Typ da committed hat, dann ist es ganz schön schwierig von Hand
das Commit wieder rückgängig zu machen und in die Form zu bringen, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Bei anderen Versionsverwaltungssystemen wäre die logischste Schlussfolgerung jetzt, ich
rolle zurück, also quasi auf den Stand vor diesem Commit, was alles kaputt gemacht hat,
weil, ne, dieses Commit hat unser tolles Programm zerstört. Also würde ich jetzt normalerweise
hier rauf zurückrollen, weil ich weiß, davor ging es noch alles. Das ist ja auch, sieht
man es wieder, ist eines der großen Vorteile von einem Versionsverwaltungssystem, da kann
ich sowas machen, sprich, ich hab hier meine vergangenen Stände relativ gut beschrieben
und weiß auch jetzt noch, wie das Programm heute Morgen ausgeschaut hat, oder ich kann
mir den Stand von heute Morgen auch angucken. Also, wie macht man das jetzt? Also mal angenommen,
dieses Feature hätte sich jetzt über 20 Dateien verteilt und hätte 500 Zeilen geändert
und ich hab dieses Feature nicht programmiert, also ich weiß gar nicht genau, was der da
eigentlich gemacht hat. Ich will es einfach rückgängig machen. Ich will es einfach rückgängig
machen und, wie ich es gerade gesagt hab, einfach auf den Stand vorher zurückrollen
ist mit Git nicht. Dafür gibt es bei Git den Befehl Revert. Revert macht genau das, was
ich vorher von Hand gemacht hab, nämlich der dreht das Comet einfach um. Also, ich
zeig es euch hier nochmal. In dem letzten Comet weiß Git ja, dass ich, ich zeig mal
nur das letzte an, Git weiß ja, in dem letzten Comet wurden diese Zeilen geändert, hinzugefügt.
So, und Git Revert ist ziemlich simpel in dem, was es macht, das dreht das einfach um.
Also sprich, wenn in diesem Comet diese Zeilen hinzugekommen sind, wird ein Git Revert diese
Zeilen löschen. Zeilen, die gelöscht werden, wird ein Git Revert hinzufügen. Ein Git Revert
macht quasi einfach ein umgedrehtes Comet. So, und wenn es jetzt wirklich von jemand
anderem, was entwickelt worden wäre, dieses Feature, was jetzt unser Programm kaputt
gemacht hat und halt sich über 500 Zeilen erstrecken würde und ich will einfach nur,
dass das Programm wieder geht, dann würde ich sagen Git Revert, letztes Comet, da kann
man jetzt entweder die Comet ID nehmen oder man kann es auch abkürzen, wir nehmen jetzt
mal die Comet ID, das ist glaube ich einfacher und jetzt sagt er mir auch hier, ok, das
ist ein neues Comet, aber dieses Comet löscht einfach nur die Veränderung von eben diesem
Comet. Wenn ich jetzt in meine History gucke, ist im Endeffekt genauso, wie ich das vorher
von Hand gemacht habe, bloß, dass das Git Revert automatisch für mich gemacht hat. Das
Comet ist immer noch da, aber der Inhalt ist wieder weg. Also sprich, die Dateien sind
wieder auf dem Stand von da, aber ich bin in der History nicht auf dem Stand von da,
sondern dort. So viel zu, wenn man Mist Cometet hat, wie kriegt man es wieder weg. Find ich
ist eines der wichtigsten Sachen, die man wissen muss, die meisten Git Tutorials machen
das irgendwann am Schluss. Und jetzt kann ich das nämlich auch pushen ohne Force, weil
die History immer noch 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, also aufeinander basiert und nichts mehr verschwindet
zwischendurch. So was sieht man ab und zu mal, also sprich, wenn man den öffentlichen Git
Push guckt, wird man das ab und zu mal sehen, Revert von bla bla bla. Also sprich, da ist
irgendwie ein Comet reingekommen, was irgendwas kaputt gemacht hat und anstatt es lange zu
suchen oder es zu fixen, sagt man, ok, wir Reverten das einfach erstmal wieder, dann
ist es weg. Aber es ist halt wohlgemerkt aus dem Programm raus, also hier aus dem Bash
Script ist es raus, allerdings in der Git History ist es noch drin. Das ist wichtig
zu wissen. So. Nächste Frage ist, was ist ein Branch? Wir haben uns jetzt angeguckt,
die History, wir haben uns angeguckt, dass jedes Comet eine eindeutige Aldi hat. Ja cheat,
ich weiß, dass meine Comet Messages wahnsinnig aussagekräftig sind, aber die sind aussagekräftiger
als die meisten Comet Messages, die ich auf der Arbeit lese. So. Also, wir wissen jetzt,
wie man was committet, wie man, wenn man Mist committet hat, das wieder wegbekommt und wir
wissen, wie man was zu einem Remoteserver pushen kann. Das sind schon mal ganz gute
Grundlagen, wo man erstmal mitarbeiten kann und wo man auch schon zumindest in beschränktem
Umfang zusammenarbeiten kann. Äh, zockst du heute noch Cod? Ich hatte eigentlich vor
heute Cod zu spielen, allerdings fängt gleich der Overwatch World Cup an und ich wollte
ich gucken. Aber eins, ich muss jetzt mal eine Sache gucken, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Kommuniert er das? Nein, ich guck das einfach nur. Naja, immerhin 45.000, das ist für
immer noch relativ viel, ja. So. Jetzt gucken wir uns aber nochmal an, zwei Sachen muss
man uns noch anschauen, bevor wir so mit den absoluten Git Basics durch sind und zwar
sind, was sind Branches und wie führt man zwei Branches wieder zusammen. Das ist ein
Thema, generell kann man über diese ganzen Sachen stundenlang erzählen und wir sind
wahrscheinlich auch jetzt mit diesem Stream heute noch nicht ganz fertig, weil wirklich
weit kommen tut man damit noch nicht, es fehlen noch ein paar Sachen. Aber was wichtig zu
wissen ist, was sind Branches. Branches sind ähm, Namen für einen Commit, könnte man
so sagen, wo man später noch neue oben drauf legen kann. Ähm, also sprich, ich kann jetzt,
dass ich hier im Master Branch drinnen bin, ist einfach nur, weil das so defaultmäßig
ist, weil man in irgendeinem Branch drinnen sein muss. Ähm, Branch ist, gibt's bestimmt
ein schönes Bild dazu, genau. Ein Branch ist sowas, also quasi, man hat einen Baum, man
hat einen Ast und davon gehen halt so kleine Branchen, kleinere Äste von raus. Und so
ähnlich ist das in Git auch, ich hab hier meinen Master Branch, also quasi das default
Ding, in dem ich standardmäßig entwickle. Wenn ich jetzt was neues einbauen möchte
in unser tolles Bash Crypt. Wenn ich jetzt da irgendwas neues drin einbauen will, was
ganz furchtbar experimentell ist zum Beispiel, von dem ich nicht weiß, ob es überhaupt
funktionieren wird, dann wäre das ziemlich blöd, ich würde das im Master Branch entwickeln,
Committen und zwischendrin pushen, weil dann kriegen ja alle Leute die Version, die vielleicht
kaputt ist. Und deswegen macht man sich dann meistens einen eigenen Branch auf dafür,
man kann auch den Master entwickeln, vor allem wenn man alleine an irgendwas entwickelt.
Hehe, der Nilsson. Übrigens Nilsson, was mir gerade einfällt, hat dich auf Twitter
in dem letzten Mal ein Joe angeschrieben, ob du über seine Rechnerzusammenstellung drüber
gucken könntest. Das wäre nett von dir, wenn du mal drüber gucken könntest, weil
da tut sich da sehr schwer. Genau, wir machen jetzt, wir wollen jetzt ein super experimentelles
hochkritisches Feature in unser tolles Bash Crypt einbauen. Zum Beispiel, wie das Serious
Max gerade schreibt im Chat Echo123. Ganz kritisch, furchtbar schlimm und das wollen
wir nicht in unserem Hauptentwicklungszweig, Hauptentwicklungsbranche machen, weil wir
wollen ja da eine Version drin haben, die erstmal, auf den ersten Blick lauffähig
ist. Deswegen macht man dann einen eigenen Branch auf, dazu sagt man Git Checkout minus
B. Zum Beispiel, äh, nennen wir jetzt den Branch neues Feature. Das ist vielleicht
auch nicht der beste Name. So, äh, und jetzt hab ich quasi den Stand, ich geh nochmal
zurück. Fuck, ich hab meine Alias hier nicht, nicht, Git Checkout Master. Äh, jetzt hab
ich quasi den Stand von meiner History genommen und einfach, wie man es hier oben sieht, ähm,
da noch einen weiteren Namen dran geklebt. Also, auf dieses Comet, dieses Comet kann
ich zur Zeit mit unterschiedlichen Namen ansprechen. Beispielsweise mit Master, mit, ja, FakeGit
Hat Master, äh, oder eben auch mit neues Feature. Alle diese Branches zeigen aktuell noch auf
dieses Comet. Jetzt hab ich es aber aufgesplittet, indem ich einen neuen Branch gemacht hab und
wenn ich jetzt neue Sachen committe, dann sind die erstmal nur in neues Feature drinne
und nicht in Master. Also, zum Beispiel, wir machen jetzt hier mal ganz, ganz kritisch,
Echo123. Das ist wirklich, das ist hoch expert, wie schreibt man das überhaupt? Kritisch.
Das ist ganz kritisch, Echo123, das kann echt in die Hose gehen, ja. Äh, das, das committe
ich jetzt noch mit, ähm, es ist hier, Achtung, gefährlich. So, jetzt hab ich ein neues Comet
angelegt für mein ganz kritisches, äh, ganz kompliziertes, kritisches Feature und das
ist jetzt nur in diesem Branch drinnen. Und wenn man hier auf mein FakeGit Hat noch mal
geht, dann sieht man auch aktuell gibt es woanders überhaupt eine Branch Anzeige. Ah,
hier, Branch. Es gibt aktuell nur Master Branch. Jetzt kann ich das pushen als, ähm, in diesem
Branch und das hat jetzt den großen Vorteil, dass der Master Branch auf einer Version geblieben
ist, die geht, die funktioniert, allerdings mein neues Feature Branch eben diesen super
gefährlichen Comet enthält, der vielleicht alles kaputt gemacht hat. So, und die Version
dieses Scripts kann man jetzt erstmal ordentlich testen und ausprobieren und wenn dieses neue
Feature sich dann als brauchbar herausgestellt hat, dann kann ich sagen, ich nehme das neue
Feature jetzt und schiebe das wieder zurück in den Master Branch. Aber bis ich das gemacht
hab, ist im Master Branch weiterhin ein relativ stabiler Stand und alle experimentellen Entwicklungen
hier in diesem neuen Feature Branch. Ja, Silbaro, genau dafür ist das sinnvoll. Silbaro hat
geschrieben, neue Branches sind voll für neue Versionen oder Betas. Richtig. Man verwendet
Branches für unterschiedliche Sachen, entweder gibt es, also eigentlich kann man es machen
wie man will, aber es gibt so ein paar Konventionen, wie man das in Neudeutsch nennt, Best Practice,
es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die haben sich so etabliert, also man macht Branches beispielsweise
für neue Features. Man macht Branches auch für alte Release Versionen, wo man vielleicht
noch was dran fixen muss. Das macht der Lidlxkernel beispielsweise so. Man kann auch Hotfix Branches
machen. In der Regel macht man Branches immer dann, wenn man erstmal den eigentlichen Stand
nicht verändern will und erstmal ausprobieren möchte. Deswegen ist es in den Reb, ich muss
meine Git-Aliasse hier einrichten, sonst dreh ich durch. Deswegen ist es auch bei den Git-Repos,
die ich verwalte, so, dass in den Master-Branche außer mir keiner pushen darf. Das hab ich
durchgeblockt. Außer mir darf in 5 Branches keiner pushen, unter anderem Master. So ist
sichergestellt, dass zumindest ein gewisses Maß an Kontrolle vorhanden ist, was im Master
kommt und was nicht. Weil es ist einfach so, dass Master eben der Standard-Branch ist,
auf dem Leute ihre neuen Entwicklungen aufsetzen. Und der sollte halbwegs stabil sein. Das ist
nicht das stable Release, was ich jetzt irgendwie zum Download anbiete oder so. Das sollte aber
ein halbwegs stabiler Entwicklungsstand sein, wo andere Leute drauf aufsetzen können. Das
Ding Master heißt, ist aber wie gesagt auch einfach nur ein Name, genauso wie das Origin
des Remotes. Das ist einfach nur ein Name, ich kann das Ding auch umbenennen. Also wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise nicht will, dass es standardmäßig einen Master-Branch gibt,
ich kann's auch umbenennen. Ich kann jetzt auch sagen, Master zu stable. Was bescheuert
ist, weil in der Regel ist das eben der aktive Entwicklungs-Branch, der aber halt nicht kaputt
sein sollte. Und jetzt können wir beispielsweise ein neues Feature testen, alles wunderbar.
Und wenn ich fertig bin, und das werden wir nächstes Mal noch ein bisschen vertiefen,
weil dann gucken wir uns mal an, was passiert, wenn das Zusammenführen Konflikte gibt und
sowas in der Richtung. Wenn ich damit fertig bin, wenn das getestet ist, und nachdem ich
diesen Branch gepusht habe, können das natürlich auch andere Leute bei sich ausprobieren,
indem sie einfach eben mit Git Checkout den Branch wechseln. Dann kommt das Ganze wieder
zurück in Master. Ach fuck, wie konnte man Graf mal nochmal Git Lock? So, aktuell sieht
unsere History noch ziemlich gerade aus. Erstes Comet, zweites Comet, drittes Comet, viertes
Comet, jedes Comet setzt aufeinander auf und alles ist gut. So sieht aktuell unsere
History aus. Wenn ich jetzt fertig bin mit meinem neuen Feature, wenn ich das fertig
entwickelt habe, kann ich sagen, ok, ich nehme dieses neue Feature und schiebe es in mein
Hauptentwicklungsbranche rein, also in Master. Was mache ich mit Git Merge? Diese Option
kann ich nächstes Mal erklären, das muss ich jetzt machen, dass ich überhaupt was sehe.
So, jetzt kann ich das Mergen, dann gibt es ein eigenes Merge Comet und wenn ich jetzt
in meine History reingucke, sehe ich, siehe da, das sind die Comets, die wir schon ein
bisschen hatten und jetzt kommt hier ein neues Comet, das kommt aber aus einem anderen Branch,
ich meine, das ist hier so ASCII-Graf gemalt, ja, man kann sich schon so ungefähr vorstellen.
Bis hier ging es immer geradeaus und da kam aus einem zweiten Branch, hier wurde es abgespalten
aus dem eigentlichen Branch, was committet und das ging dann parallel und hier in diesem
letzten Comet wurde es wieder zusammengefügt. Ja, natürlich, das war jetzt wirklich die
absolut ideale Zustand. Es kann ohne Probleme passieren, dass zwei Leute parallel an der
gleichen Datei was geändert haben und dass sich das dann nicht verträgt beim Mergen.
Aber das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an und das nächste Mal habe ich mir vorher auch
ein bisschen mehr Gedanken gemacht, was ich eigentlich erzählen will, weil es hat ein
bisschen gedauert, bis ich reingekommen bin. Zumindest, was wir uns heute angeguckt haben,
damit kommt man zumindest auf GitHub so basic-mäßig schon mal ganz gut zurecht, man kann sich
in den Repo klonen, man kann was editieren, man kann was committen, man kann was pushen,
das sind erstmal die wichtigsten Sachen und man kann Branches wechseln, wenn man vielleicht
was ausprobieren will. Ich meine, es könnte ja sein, dass man ein GitHub-Projekt sich
angucken möchte und halt nicht den Masterstand, den Hauptentwicklungsstand, von dem man sich
angucken will, sondern wirklich irgendein experimentales Feature, weil einen das eben
interessiert. Also Branch wechseln ist auch eine wichtige Geschichte und die logische
Schlussfolgerung daraus ist, man muss auch wissen, wie man zwei Branches wieder zusammenführt.
Ja, auskernFox mache ich auch so. Er hat geschrieben, wie hältst du es mit merge und commit? Ich
fahre immer ganz gut mit Branches, in die nur committed wird und Branches, in die nur
gemerged wird. Das mache ich ähnlich, mit immer mal kleinen Ausnahmen. Also, was nächstes
Mal ist morgen Mittag? Was meinst du? Also, ich mache das immer mit kleinen Ausnahmen,
weil manchmal ist es einfach viel einfacher, wenn man wirklich da irgendwie einen Zahlendreher
drin hat oder sowas. Also, mal angenommen. Mal angenommen, wir haben jetzt eine neue
Version und irgendwie die QS stellt fest, ist irgendwas kaputt. Natürlich kann ich
demjenigen dann sagen, der damit was zu tun hat, hier mach mal einen Hotfix-Branch oder
sonst was auf, das ist schon sinnvoll. Zu der Reihenlehre nach, ja. Aber wenn das mal
angenommen wirklich sowas ganz furchtbar Simples ist, dass der einfach, keine Ahnung,
Zahlendreher bei einer IP oder bei einem Name oder sowas falsch hat, dann setzen wir
uns auch manchmal zu mir an den Rechner, gehen auf den jeweiligen Branch drauf, also auf
den Beta, auf den aktuellen Beta-Branch und machen dann halt commit da drauf, obwohl da
eigentlich nichts drauf committed werden soll. Das kann ich dann aber entscheiden und wenn
ich das einfach sehe, dass es nur ein Zahlendreher ist oder so, dann sag ich dann, ja okay, komm,
lass machen, machen wir keinen extra Branch auf. Aber auf ScanFolks normalerweise mach
ich das auch so, ja. Alle Leute haben gefälligst, den eigenen Branch zu entwickeln, es zu testen
und quasi als Merchrequest, Pullrequest, wie man es nennt, wie man es auch immer macht,
einzureichen als Änderung für Master. Tobi tickt, benutzt du eine Git GUI um Merchkonflikte
zu erkennen? Na ja, Merchkonflikte erkennt man auf jeden Fall, wenn es sobald sie gibt,
weil da geht es nicht weiter. Ansonsten verwende ich eigentlich keine GUI für, ich mach das,
wenn es kleine übersichtliche Merchkonflikte sind, aber das gucken wir uns das nächste
Mal an. Wenn es kleine übersichtliche Merchkonflikte sind, mach ich das hier einfach auf der Kommandozeile
im Wim. Oder aber, was auch ein ganz gutes Merch, ganz gut Merch-Diff an sich hat, ist
Visual Studio Code. Aber normalerweise sind, ich weiß, dass viele Leute, die früher SVN
verwendet haben, für die ist Merchen und Merchkonflikte und solche Sachen, das ist
für die, das ist kurz bevor das Rechenzentrum implodiert quasi, das ist in Git alles nicht
so wild. Also die meisten Merchkonflikte sind recht übersichtlich. Und ich meine, ich hab
jetzt noch nie an sowas Großem beispielsweise, oder ich hatte noch nie die Verantwortung
für das Repo, sowas Großem wie beispielsweise der Git, äh, der Linux-Könnel, ja. Aber
wer hat das schon? Da gibt es eine Handvoll Leute auf der Welt, die das haben. Aber die
Repo, äh, die Repos bei uns sind relativ groß. Und die Merchkonflikte, die es da gibt, sind
eigentlich recht übersichtlich. Das ist nicht so wild. Weil es ist so, dass, es ist ja meistens
in einem Projekt, wo mehrere Leute dran arbeiten, schon so ein bisschen aufgeteilt, so wer ist
für was zuständig. Also es ist selten, dass quasi 3-4 Leute an den gleichen Dateien was
editieren, ja. Der eine kümmert sich um das, der eine kümmert sich eher um das. Und klar,
es gibt auch mal Dateien, wo parallel dran editiert wird. Aber meistens, meistens editieren
die Leute an unterschiedlichen Dateien. Dementsprechend gibt es gar keine Merchkonflikte. Oder wenn
es Merchkonflikte gibt, ist es relativ einfach zu lösen. Entweder ist es so offensichtlich,
dass man das direkt, dass ich es direkt selber sehe. Oder aber, naja, ich nehme einfach die
zwei Leute, von denen die Comets sind und die Bratsches sind, die Konflikten und sag
ja, Jungs, werdet euch mal einig, wie muss es denn aussehen am Ende. Und das ist meistens
nicht, nicht großartig kompliziert. Da sind vielleicht 3-4 Zeilen dann, die da konflikten
oder so. Also es hält sich in Grenzen. Welches Webinterface benutzt ihr in der Firma für
Pull-Request? GitLab. Wir haben früher GitLab verwendet. Und ich fand GitLab auch ziemlich
gut. Ich hätte auch GitLab weiterverwendet. Aber die Firma hat sich ganz viele Atlassian-Tools
gekauft. Und jetzt haben wir Bitbucket. Ja, Sebaro. Das stimmt. Irgendjemand hat eben
was zu Pull-Request. Ach nee, hier war eine Frage drinne. Welches Webinterface benutzt
ihr in der Firma für Pull-Request? GitLab. Bitbucket. Bitbucket. Das ist auch ganz gut.
Also im Vergleich zu anderen Kack-Business-Software ist Bitbucket wirklich in Ordnung. Ich finde
GitLab auch gut. Wobei GitLab mittlerweile ziemlich aufgebläht ist. Ah gut, es ist
halt eine Ruby-On-Wales-Anwendung. So, ich hoffe euch hat der Stream gefallen. Ich gebe
zu, das war am Anfang ein bisschen chaotisch, weil ich selbst nicht genau wusste, was ich
alles erzählen muss, in welcher Reihenfolge und so. Das nächste Mal mache ich mir ein
bisschen mehr Gedanken drüber. Aber ich hoffe so die ganz grundlegenden Basics sind
zu rüber gekommen. Also sprich, man könnte jetzt ein Repo von GitHub klonen und dort
eine Änderung mit drin und machen und vielleicht vorher einen eigenen Branch aufmachen und
das Ganze pushen. Morgen geht es weiter. Ja, ich kann morgen weiter machen, Cheat. Hast
du Vorschläge, was ich morgen machen soll? Also was immer super ist, ist wenn die Leute
Fragen haben zu irgendwelchen Sachen, dann ist es einfach an roten Fahrten zu finden,
was man erzählen kann. Wie schalt es mit dem Discord-Server aus, habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Also was ich morgen, ich werde morgen ein bisschen versteckte Sachen zeigen, die aber
recht praktisch sind. Zum Beispiel, wie man Fehler finden kann. Es gibt in Git eingebaute
Tools, die einem das Fehler finden ziemlich erleichtern. Also mit Fehler finden meine
ich jetzt zum Beispiel, man stellt halt wirklich in der Beta-Phase irgendwie fest, es geht
was nicht und dann geht es darum zu finden oder den Comet rauszufinden, der es kaputt
gemacht hat. Das ist in Git viel einfacher als gedacht. Flash Gordon fragt, was ist mit
Stashing und Staging? Du meinst, was der Unterschied ist? Verstehe ich das richtig? Oder ob ich
es zeigen soll? Ja, Fatal, das stimmt. So richtige Probleme kriegt man eh erst, wenn man es verwendet.
Ja, Cherrypicks ist aber schon ein bisschen, das brauchen die meisten Leute nicht. Das
brauche ich, wenn man sich um sowas kümmert, quasi als Verantwortlicher für die Repos
und so und für die unterschiedlichen Entwicklungsstufen. Da braucht man öfters mal Cherrypick, aber
die meisten Leute brauchen es eigentlich nicht. Ganz simpel gesagt, Flash Gordon, hat Stash
und Stage eigentlich überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun, das sind komplett unterschiedliche
Sachen. Stashing ist Zwischenspeichern von Änderungen, wenn man einen Branch wechseln
muss und Staging ist das, was ich vorgemerkt habe für das nächste Comet, um es mal ganz
kurz zu sagen. Wenn ich etwas adde und noch nicht committe, dann ist es gestaged für
das nächste Comet und wenn ich etwas editiert habe, aber jetzt nicht committen will, weil
ich vielleicht den Branch wechseln muss, weil mein Chef gerade zu mir gekommen ist und
gesagt hat, du musst etwas machen, dann stash ich quasi in Zwischenspeicher. Ja, Fatal,
das ist cool, dann hat es sich am wenigsten gelohnt, dass ich etwas dazu erzählt habe.
Ja, dann mache ich das mal morgen. Es gibt noch einige coole Sachen, die man zeigen kann,
wobei man sagen muss, bei Git ist es so, man kann damit alles machen, man kann damit machen,
was man will und wie man es will, man sollte aber aufpassen, dass man es nicht übertreibt.
Nur weil ich 500 Branches anlegen kann, muss ich das nicht unbedingt machen. Git selbst
stört das überhaupt nicht, Git ist mit 500 Branches noch genauso schnell wie mit 2 Branches,
aber es ist halt nicht wirklich übersichtlich. Nur weil ich 5 Branches auf einmal merken
kann, weil das Git zulässt, muss ich das nicht unbedingt machen. Also, man kann alles
mitmachen, es ist auch vollkommen egal, wie man das macht, aber wenn ich bei jedem Comet
Force pushen muss, mache ich irgendwas verkehrt. Wie wäre es mit Versionstacks? Ja, könnte
man auch machen. Bei der Gelegenheit könnte man eigentlich noch mal sagen, dass Comet
IDs und Branches und Texts relativ ähnlich sind. Rebase, Rebase könnte man auch mal machen.
Rebase ist wichtig, wenn man halt seine eigenen Comets aufräumen will, bevor man sie einreicht
als Pull oder Merchrequest. Ja, das werde ich morgen machen. Und jetzt werde ich Overwatch
World Cup gucken. Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen. Übrigens wir haben ja heute unsere Linux
FM verwendet, die wir vor paar Wochen eingerichtet haben zusammen im Stream. Wem das noch nicht
aufgefallen ist. Gut. Dann macht's gut, bis morgen. Tschüss.